2 and a half £1,000
it costs today installment for small
two-room apartment bought in a loan for 25 years
A whole generation has grown up in Poland
which did not have
and will never have
no other perspectives on your own corner
than a mortgage
An alternative to the less wealthy
is renting on the private market
often with roommates to make it cheaper
a rental prices
the rental prices knock down the room in Warsaw
More expensive than in Rome
in Brussels or Hamburg
Gdansk has the same prices as Berlin
More than 1 / 3 of apartments in Poland are overcrowded
and apartments for cheap rent Just not built
flat plus turned out to be a big flop
What local governments do
sell their own municipal resource and in this crisis
Not everyone loses
because someone earns banks
developers and speculators
and this is why
that the Polish state simply withdrew
washed its hands left these people to their fate
Forcing them to go into debt
to take dishonest
Risky loans
Each of us has to live somewhere.